prenez georges querry ancien patron de
l'unité de coordination de la lutte
antiterroriste
vous partagez les propos que convient
d'entendre de la part de gilles sacaze
c'est une question d'idéologie menace
cette ce combat contre contre le
terrorisme oui totalement le combat va
être long va être très difficile
quinze jours même pas après l'assassinât
d'un professeur en a maintenant
ce triple meurtre qui est absolument
inacceptable et les services sont
engagées que ce soit en france soit à
l'étranger la volonté elle est là la
détermination et à la le seul problème
c'est que on est face à une menace qui
est complètement diluée qui est
fanatique qui est dans les cerveaux il
faudrait pouvoir les perquisitionné dans
les cerveaux de tous ces types pour
savoir quelles sont leurs intentions
hélas ça donne l'impression que nous
sommes passif mais ça n'est absolument
pas le cas il faut voir un peu les
attentats qui ont été déjoués ces
dernières années il y en a eu de
nombreux et puis il est bien il ya ce
risque d'individus qui nous échappe qui
passe sous les radars et qui soudain
surgissent pour tuer au risque
d'ailleurs eux mêmes d'être tué parce
que c'est ce qu'ils recherchent mais
effectivement dans l'autre pays ils
n'auraient pas été pris vivant chez nous
oui oui vous vous évoquez 7
cette attaque qui survient très
soudainement on le rappelle c'est la
deuxième en deux semaines
comment est ce qu'on explique que la
aujourd'hui en ce moment
on assiste à une résurgence ou en tout
cas à des faits d'une extrême violence
pourquoi aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui met
le feu aux poudres si on a besoin de
quelque chose pour mettre le feu pour
nous ce qui me concerne je pense qu'il
est extrêmement difficile et compliqué
de se livrer à des analyses rationnelle
des constructions intellectuelles
rationnelle pour un phénomène qui ne
l'est pas on est dans le fanatisme on
est dans l'idéologie enfin seul
l'idéologie c'est de l'art de la
religion mal assimilé mal restituer
c'est de la haine de la violence
peut-être je dirais peut-être mais ce
que j'avance là évidemment je la vends
ce avec beaucoup de prudence
peut-être que le procès de charlie hebdo
et l'histoire des dessins des autres
savent peut-être l'été on a peut-être
souffler sous les braises sur les
braises
chez les esprits simples c'est à dire
qu'on a à faire quand même à des
individus dont l'intelligence et la
raison ne sont pas les caractéristiques
principales est peut-être que le procès
de charlie hebdo et les polémiques sur
les dessins sur mahomet damas m pardon à
réactiver et bien c'est de haine cette
violence qui est quasiment
consubstantiel à la religion chez
certains individus